you have a couple years ago when I
reviewed the Ashton Kutcher Steve Jobs
movie I said I was watching jobs and I
was like how much better with this movie
have been if it was written by Aaron
Sorkin and that life has given us that
so let's review that Steve Jobs so Steve
Jobs was written by Aaron Sorkin's
directed by Danny Boyle stars Michael
Fassbender as Steve Jobs and ultimately
answers the question of why about Steve
Jobs a lot of movies answer the who what
when where and how but the most
interesting question about a character
and about a person is the why why is
that person that way why does he see the
world that way why does he do the things
he does probably my favorite other
questions because it's the least
answered of the questions even if you
get an answer for the why you don't like
the answer you get nonetheless an Aaron
Sorkin ease dialogue between characters
this movie explores Steve Jobs and who
he was as a person fascinatingly enough
it doesn't explore the guy's life as you
would think it would explore his life
this movie like most movies broken up
into three acts however all of these
acts take place backstage or in a
building where steve job is going to
give a presentation of some sort it's
really the intense dialogue between him
and other people that takes place
backstage before this presentation and
using that formula explores who Steve
Jobs was and I'm a fan of Aaron Sorkin's
writing I love dialogue movies that
actually nail the dialogue this movie
thrives on dialogue it's a dialogue
movie really nothing happens in this
movie except dialogue and when a movie
goes that angle and hits it it's great
if it doesn't hit it it's boring as
luckily this isn't one of the boring
ones one of the great ones does Michael
Fassbender is perfect as Steve Jobs this
movie went through a lot of changes also
I guess Christian Bale was gonna be
Steve Jobs at one point what we got with
Michael Fassbender and this creative
team is his Steve Jobs that you look at
you're like we all knew Steve Jobs was a
dick
he was intense he was a douche to people
we get that but in watching this movie
you feel like you kind of get how Steve
Jobs brain works you're like I kind
understand why he would say some of the
things he says and why he sees things a
certain way why these things irritate
him the more seen Seth Rogen was even
like you don't write code what is it you
actually do what you do is you think
things up and you have a team of people
who bust their ass while you take all
the credit and in that it illustrates
that Steve Jobs was very imaginative
sometimes too imaginative for the
technology that existed at the time
couldn't always do the things he wanted
to do but in
evaders are like that they should be
like that I really loved the
relationship between him and his
daughter all this his girl that he's
like she's not my daughter but you know
that she is he's just super in denial
about it you can see a point in this
movie where he just has this dumbfounded
look like that's my daughter the thing
about this movie is it taking place
backstage and dialogue between
characters and really that's the fruit
of the movie I wanted to see other
things in this I wanted to see how he
started Apple I wanted to see how he
started the tech in the garage like we
always heard branded we got a movie that
showed that I just wanted to see a movie
that showed that that was done by a
better creative thing but it sure Danny
Boyle and Aaron Sorkin would probably
looked me in the eyes and be like yeah
you want that kind of redundancy a team
did do that you got that movie and
that's why we don't do it that way all
right fair enough guys in the end I
thought Steve Jobs was great Michael
Fassbender was great as Steve Jobs Aaron
Sorkin did a great job writing the movie
Danny Boyle did a great job directing
the movie it feels a bit isolated at
times and doesn't explore Steve Jobs
life to the extent you might want to see
but it's impressive how they still
explore Steve Jobs the person in the
isolated scenarios that they actually
have him in and I will say Steve Jobs is
certainly worth watching and worth
buying on blu-ray right so Steve Jobs
have you seen it what did you think
about it
judging by the numbers not a lot of you
have so you should watch it though then
tell me whatever you thought and comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]